I love the fat
you talked about the hubris because it
has been especially in the last say the
bill anthropol moment the Bill Gates
moment in which a lot of people who are
brilliant and have a particular kind of
talent believe that that talent is
directly translatable to the the world
of you know poverty alleviation or
getting rid of major diseases or fixing
education but but you wonder what the
what that is built on because they've
been people working on these of these
issues for ya a long time yeah and I
think they're really different and hard
hard issues in other ways now they
certainly these people such as myself or
the other people do this bring values I
mean the idea of you know of how you
create management systems and how you
have measurement systems and how you you
know create teams I mean there's a whole
bunch of great stuff that that does
carry over but there's other things that
don't I mean the most the most
significant one in my view that I've
learned you know parley being here as a
part of the community at Yale too is
that you know in and on for-profit
enterprise as the CEO anybody who's not
somebody I want on my team I can fire
and that's one of your most important
tools to managing your organization is
who is there around the table and are
they the right people or not and that's
not always true in the education system
you can't just go in and fire the people
who you don't think of performing you
know you've got restrictions on that
that the society has agreed to place on
that and so you know there are real
hardcore differences that I think people
from my world get in there and just tear
their hair out because they just can't
believe they can't make things happen
the way they're used to making things
happen I'm so glad you know one of our
previous guess was Julian Bond the great
Civil Rights icon and when you think
about social change and equality for
african-americans or for women or for
the LGBT community
how do you fire a movement who in the
movement do you fire and how does a
person who is expert in supplier
monopoly or expert delivery systems you
know of medicines which are great but
how are those translatable when you're
dealing with trying to do a systemic
change for social justice yeah but
people can heart problem I know people
think they can do it they can reinvent
everything so but anyway I do think
there are things that are really
wonderful that that community brings in
and there's other things they just have
to learn they have to learn themselves